hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley
baby hey everybody out there and welcome
back to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
find if they go up classy
or if they're a complete piece of [ __ ]
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
glorious day here at
gash digital studios in the east village
gang it's fan
appreciation daddy all right it's
[ __ ] bat night it's free hot dog get
your bobble heads everybody
that's right it's [ __ ] casual friday
it's just going to be
uncle hank aunt kippy and the gang
that's it we're going to be reading all
the emails we're going to be in the live
chat we're in there right now baby it's
going to be a good time
we want to extend our deepest
appreciation to everybody out there for
supporting the podcast
so this is just for you guys baby we
love you my co-host is sitting directly
across from me
he's currently in panic mode right now
trying to secure an apartment it's so
bad that he came to me
to co-sign where i had to cough up my
[ __ ]
tax statement my bank records i do a lot
of shady [ __ ] late at night
this guy's all over me gang he's
everybody's best pal
give it the [ __ ] up for kevin james
brian hey everybody bit of a tense day
here in the war room yeah put this away
by the way all right hey [ __ ]
police agreement your social security
number floating around
hit the zoo somebody zoom in on that get
yourself a pre-owned civic
i got enough nigerian princes on the on
the payroll
buddy i love this shirt by the way no
boundaries
is is that the name of the brand that's
the name of the brand no boundaries
where'd you get a woodstock that thing
is [ __ ] tight smoking doobies
listening to hendrix
yeah foley garcia over here look at them
so my body falls in my clothes fully got
really into the 60s and no one ever saw
him again
far out buddy happy to be here
good to see you pal speak in his shirts
there's you need one you're trying to
take the one off my back
buddy i just threw a hail mary for a
[ __ ] uh cosi if anybody in the live
chat wants to be a co-signer for an
apartment in washington heights
let a brother know let's get into this
real quick let's talk about a little
garbage right here
hold on let's get some business out of
the way we got [ __ ] shirts to sell oh
yeah
let's go what the [ __ ] are we going to
change that tax form what do you mean i
got merch money coming in let's go
uh yeah guys uh so we're doing uh a one
week
uh exclusive sale of uh we have four
shirts we have a garbagio shirt garbagio
uh in black and white and one in black
one and white we also have a clean
living shirt one in black one in white
uh they're gonna be available from
august 16th and only for one week
one week baby one week you have so get
those [ __ ] orders in
because then they're never available
ever again [ __ ] going out of business
sales
everything must go all sales final gippy
needs games i'll say it is sure
all right look at no boundaries
it's also at walmart by the way if
you're shopping in the area for big and
tall
check it out uh yeah guys so they'll be
available on uh
podcastmerch.com that's what it is right
podcast merch that's the name of its
podcast march yeah you'll be available
on podcastmerch.com for one week only
get those crack open the piggy banks
head to a coin store do whatever you got
to do
start rolling change of what sell you we
need this sell your bitcoin
whatever you need to do he's getting
kicked out of his apartment for god's
sakes
things are tough when does that start uh
august 16th so sunday sunday to saturday
will be a one-week run
sunday to saturday very nice check it
out yeah so that's that
now back to those in fact all right so
this is how garbage i am i had as foley
to be a co-signer
let me tell you on the car ride over
here i almost fell out of the car
this question came out of [ __ ] his
butt
no one awesome has ever asked me and i
didn't even qualify
because we just went over my uh my my
bank statements and
it ain't good well hold on for the
listener and the car ride down here
fully sewing out some roundabout figures
that sound pretty good he's the things
there he's there's commas there's a
bunch of zeros involved
he's talking about all offshore accounts
and everything i gotta talk to turbo tax
nobody's [ __ ] up over there i made 50
grand last year
when the rubber hits the road he gave me
his 2019
[ __ ] tax return it was for 14 bucks i
said buddy you don't even make the you
don't even make the monthly payments 28
grand is what it says
i had to talk to this accountant i don't
know what he's doing
jesus christ but anyway and now you're
not going to use it no i'm not going to
use it he also
he also gave me his i needed a i needed
a bank statement and had all of his atm
charges on there
and let me tell you foley has a frequent
flyers card to the mcdonald's and blue
belt
that guy not to tina working the window
do they know you're a [ __ ] order when
you pull up
big man's here he's got a new shirt on
hey you wanna you want a quick tip for
that by the way when you go through the
drive-through so you get fresh
stuff always change something up a
little bit nah that's a garbage move
yeah that's why i'm telling everybody to
do it yeah i'm trash
yeah yeah you can't order you can't go
off menu at a mcdonald's you order a
number and keep it [ __ ] moving now
what i do
is i'll get my usual order if i'm alone
is two double cheeseburgers and a filet
of fish
okay two double cheeseburgers and a
fillet of fish two dubs
and a fish take the wax out of your ears
poor guy
a surf and turf
[Laughter]
um yeah but i get no pickles no ketchup
on the double cheeseburgers extra onions
the chopped up ones that's a [ __ ]
key ingredient at mickey d's i don't
know who the [ __ ] came up with that
whether it was ray kroc or who
but the diced onions at mickey d's are
[ __ ] on
point yeah i get extra those and a
little mac sauce on a double
cheeseburger and i add pickles to my uh
fillet fish oh do you
oh yeah i think you get your vegetables
in for the day
and also nine pounds of fries keep them
coming
lightly salted i'm watching my weight no
skin on those pickles huh oh man
off dude going off menu at a fast food
place is pure [ __ ] trouble that's how
you know you get it they make it right
there it's so much [ __ ] better
well whatever um so that's where we're
at presently yeah we're guys you talking
about bottom of the barrel we
are scraping whatever
uh mickey d surf and turf that's going
over well in the chat is it yeah that
might be that much that might be
that i mean that might be the shirts
next month surf and turf and mickey d
that's pretty good shout out to
everybody in the chat guys yeah this is
uh this is a very special episode
uh honestly i mean from the beginning of
this we've gotten
[ __ ] thousands of submissions for
questions and we can't always use them
based upon where the guest is from some
are regional some you know whatever
don't apply something just flat out
[ __ ]
racial vernacular yeah some of them
aren't too good
so but we've compiled a list and if
you're in the chat and you have a
question we're definitely going to get
to it
and also we have a list of uh i don't
know a few hundred that people have
emailed in and we'll pull out the best
ones and get to yes and if you're
listening to this and you're
you're not a subscriber at cash digital
you should because there's a shitload of
[ __ ] awesome content on there
for what seven bucks a month yeah and
you get like you get like [ __ ]
ten years of legions of skank episodes
it's like come on what are we doing here
so when we do the next one of these you
can be a part of it in the live chat
yeah
so it's called good stuff all right
let's fire off some
here i got some appetizers i mean
everybody they you you guys
i mean you guys knew we were trash
coming into this right
you didn't think we were sitting up here
on our [ __ ] high horse every week
judging but we're [ __ ] garbage oh
yeah i shop at walmart
i eat at walmart i sleep in walmart
i get my blood pressure taken at walmart
yeah
all right by the way i didn't tell you
there's something not garbage uncle hank
i got health insurance
oh good for you yeah there you go geico
no big deal
got the general i got metro i don't like
this metro plus
i like a blue cross blue shield you know
what i mean
yeah how did you get health insurance uh
i got an
email saying that uh uh that if you need
health insurance you could you can sign
up was it that nigerian prince
i had to say my deductible's 25 grand
no not a bad deal um all right let's uh
well good for you i'm happy for you i'm
gonna go to the doctor and get the works
2 000 deductible i'm getting the full
package
check the oil everything i figured i
need to go guy needs a new dipstick
can you get a new piece put on
can we stretch out the bottom half of me
a little bit
uh i'm gonna go to the cardiologist i'm
gonna go to the i'm gonna get a chest
x-ray
i'm going to get also you know how
garbage you are you texted me when you
got it
you texted me and and tom cassidy going
hey guys i just want to let you know i
got health insurance i'm like
you're like and we're like we're like yo
you guys always break my balls about me
dropping dead i'm letting you know i'm
just yeah the doctor's not gonna stop
that just
i mean they'll just take care of you
once you fall couple of perks though huh
for my bad back a couple of school buses
if you know what i mean
i was in a car accident used to drive a
plow
go in there in a wheelchair if i can
pretend that i'm blind oh man what do we
got
all right let's get into it uh a couple
of easy peasies just to start it off
little you know
i get where the deer is going it is fun
that because you know sometimes people
hit us up directly you know on instagram
or whatever
uh is that that we think the same
they think the same way we do because oh
yeah a lot of the questions like oh yeah
we've already asked that or that's
pretty good
sure well some of them actually one came
in on [ __ ] twitter i forget what it
was but i did write it down one came in
on twitter
and i had to private i didn't want to i
didn't want to like it or respond to it
because i didn't want you to see it i'm
like i've been wanting to ask this
i've been wanting to ask foley this for
[ __ ] months is it will i co-sign an
apartment for you
did you make 12 1200 bucks last year i
felt so bad man the disappointment in
your face when i was looking that over
you were like oh well all right you're
like yeah i made 10 i made [ __ ] 400
000
last year i got really good i got that
car right man
helping my buddy i got a money market
account well bush comes to the shelf
he asked me for 10 bucks yeah my dad
told me their days like you got to start
a roth i.r.a
i was like i don't know who the [ __ ]
that is but he ain't getting a dime of
my mom oh roth ira i don't know much
about him but i know that's the thing
that's
that's what you gotta do you're gonna be
homeless in a week we think i'm taking
my financial
advice someone's taking care of it
there's a little bit of cash in my
family i called my rich uncle
said yo hey [ __ ] steve get the
checkbook out kippy needs new digs
all right let's get into it let's get
into it enough [ __ ] around
let's go be bopping skating all right
this is from kroyd hope that's not your
government name
growing up were you allowed to wear
shoes in your house
yeah really what you weren't no
dude shoes in the house is garbage no
get out of here with that [ __ ]
what no if the carpet was new maybe for
a couple of weeks
all right so three weeks in the 80s
no we didn't do that [ __ ] no dude i
thought it was kind of lame i think
we've talked i thought we've talked to
you put your like feet up you'd be like
sitting watching tv with your [ __ ]
tims on
i'm not thugging it out and i thought
you got a pair of lugs on it
it was always bad the kid who had lugs
was always 20 bucks short of a pair of
tim's i respect that
all right some of my friends parents did
it it is kind of cozy but you gotta have
really good socks on for that [ __ ]
that's how you know you [ __ ] take
your shoes off you got [ __ ] holes
one pink one one ankle side trying to
[ __ ] present an image when i go to my
friend's house i don't want the [ __ ]
mom or the sister
thinking i'm a [ __ ] loser i got two
different [ __ ] socks on one's my
mom's
no we don't we didn't do it yeah i
remember one time we were traipsing mud
through the house
i don't know but you're like putting
your feet up on the coffee table you got
[ __ ] dog [ __ ] on the bottom of your
[ __ ] nike [ __ ] no [ __ ] shoes in
the house get the [ __ ] out of here with
that
um that reminds me one time i went to my
buddy's house we were like sledding or
something we were in like junior high or
snowboarding
something like it was snowing we were
out two weeks ago
hang ten dude um and
i didn't have like a pair of pants or
something so i just had my snow pants on
with like underwear
with like a pair of boxers and we went
over to my buddy's house because we
ended up not going out or something so
like everybody's like yeah take your
take you like take your snow gear off
i'm like nah dude kippy's hemmed up down
here
what are you a [ __ ] are you a swedish
ski instructor
just your panties on what the [ __ ]
is smashing brawl and panties all sexy
yeah see that's and what you're taking
your shoes off
next thing you know you're sitting
around in your underwear watching
[ __ ] duke's
hazard that's the first line of defense
once the shoes go you could end up in an
orgy real quick
guys we're having fun over here guess
they're no guests let's
do it yeah so no to that we we we were
shoes on
we were shoes off maybe if you like
walked around a little i mean but like
shoes off you go in
shoes off that brings me to a second
question
uh did you have a mud room growing up
dude mud rooms are trash dude if you
have a room in your house named after
dirt
you're garbage it just has that uh
linoleum yeah that fake
fake floor it's like peeling up on the
sides there's always like brooms and
like old shoes or something
like the litter boxes in there yeah what
a [ __ ] [ __ ] welcome to someone's
house you walk in you got a
[ __ ] first of all if you're going in
if you're company and you're going in
the side entrances that's pretty
your hosts are working for the mob or
something like that that's a bad luck
they're leading you through the back
you're about to get whacked yeah we're
front door people all the way
nah we were garage front door was open
at our house come through the garage
[ __ ]
i don't know what that's how you have
company i come over to [ __ ] to see
the kids
i gotta go through the garage take my
shoes off get the [ __ ] out of here
well i mean you came over my house she
came through the garage yeah but that
was business
not a bad garage either if you if you've
seen the if you've seen the intro to the
show that's
that's my [ __ ] that's ma's garage
what is that a two car
that's a two car and you know it's
trashy because it fits no cars
he's got a lot of [ __ ] in there oh dude
so much [ __ ] [ __ ] hoarder
dumb bro shut up shout out to denise
uh hold on we have
on this at the side door we have our
laundry room is there
yeah that's kind of that's if i you know
we were out getting all [ __ ] up that's
we'd come in that way
so i guess that's technically a mud room
but mud room's pretty fancy
i i like your house i would imagine
would have a mud room
we have the laundry room you can come in
but the garage acts as the mud room a
little bit you take your shoes off
outside like a [ __ ] gentleman
pants that is weird
weren't you cold who [ __ ] who
commandos it
i don't know if i commandoed it or maybe
i just had long johns on under there but
it was like i was like too old to be
walking around someone's house in long
johns or whatever
whatever the situation was it was a bad
look kippy's little popsicle fire
hanging out give me some ice cube i tell
you that brought back memories [ __ ] snow
pants too
why i like you get a good pair of snow
pants dude as a fat kid [ __ ] trying
to you know what around the nose you
know what the worst was
the cool if you had just pants it was
cool but if you had that [ __ ] uh
the overall pants you look like a real
[ __ ] real jamoke walking around in
the center you come with a snowball in
the face
it's coming a whitewash in my
neighborhood
[ __ ] light that kid up yeah those
things suck
all right um let's see here
all right this is from jay thank you jay
what
uh what jar of tomato sauce did you use
growing up
bonus did your mom ever add water to the
sauce
to uh get the last bit out yeah yeah
what's what brand were you i think i'm
real garbage in this
it's first of all great question that's
a fantastic
fantasy this separates the [ __ ]
garbage from the [ __ ] class right
here all right now obviously
the best thing or the least garbage
would be that your mom
put a little [ __ ] effort and made the
[ __ ] sauce
you don't even have to be italian for
that all right especially now
knowing what i know about making tomato
sauce you could [ __ ] get some peeled
tomatoes and [ __ ] throw a little
basil in there and [ __ ] do it but we
didn't do that at the foley household
we were ragu
for a long time that's trash right dude
it was like stain your mouth
i know they [ __ ] just yellow right
around my mouth i walk it from dates
i know dude i think that's like
what does that do to your kidneys it's
still in there but i'll tell you what
the ragu meat sauce ain't too bad i know
ragu is bad i think we got a little
bougie
or at least uh you know the uh the
marketing worked on us was
we did francesco and ronaldi for us
francesco ronaldi it's got the taste
we did that and i remember my mom would
bring that home and that was like you
had a cool label
hot chick on the cover we had a
co-signer for it
well i'll tell you what i don't know if
you've been to a grocery store lately
i don't know who's making the prices on
[ __ ] tomato sauce
but they're all over the place we got to
get some regulations
we
oh yeah it doesn't make sense dorios get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
if you got to go buy a jar right now
what are you buying
we do classico now classic owing batsman
all around and then we saved the jars
and i used them for my drinks because i
love drinking out of them
pack it with ice [ __ ] gatorade that's
so trashed clean living
nice got that still got the glue on the
outside of the [ __ ]
outside of the jar there's like cat hair
stuck on label on it
are you just drinking sauce is that what
you're telling us oh
always always the water always a little
bit of water i thought you were supposed
to do that
i don't know i think that's a good
that's like real that's like depression
level [ __ ] like you gotta why would you
waste it
i don't know i don't know i just thought
yeah i mean well like what wasted
you're trying to get like three cents of
tomato sauce out of a jar and spending
five minutes on it i always thought that
was kind of part of it then it like adds
to the flavor you always put a little
water in the sauce
i don't know about that were you a
spaghetti family what was
what was your pasta of choice yeah
straight spaghetti
sometime i remember there was like a few
years where we had i remember the first
time i had angel hair pasta i was gonna
say
i was like my [ __ ] hair blew back i
was like what is this [ __ ]
i'm gonna say it was probably that's why
like that's how trashy we
we were like there was like some there
was like some money from time to time
but like we were just so ingrained in
trash and i was like
as a kid that's fancy pasta meanwhile
it's a dollar nineteen a buck
uh that was probably 92 maybe when you
when when this was going on angel hair
popped in the 90s yeah
whenever [ __ ] never mind dropped like
two weeks later angel hair was walking
everywhere it was he had a song about it
on the album right it was really good
but now we don't [ __ ] with it no we
don't do it now
i stay away from that and i stay stay
away from fettuccine fettuccine never
comes out right
is that the thicker one yeah and why the
[ __ ]
how can people think like fettuccine
alfredo's like a classy dish
i think in trash i think like [ __ ]
you know olive gar
fettuccine alfredo at olive garden they
push that heavy
back in the day so like that's the big
that's it
that's what the italians are eating
fettuccine if you're doing fettuccine
you should just get a thing of nor
the noodles dude you know how many times
i've eaten those like
semi-coagulated out of a pan that's been
sitting there for five years
when you gotta cut it with your fork
they stick that's the problem with
fettuccine sticks together
oh man that is straight spaghetti at the
foley house
yeah um great question [ __ ] that was
a home [ __ ] run
this is another one this is a common one
this is from max do you prefer the
actual classy maple syrup or the garbage
maple flavored
you know log cabin [ __ ] aunt jemima [ __ ]
another great question yeah if you would
have talked to me 20 years ago
hands down i would have said aunt jemima
mrs butterworth
all day but now i don't know why i guess
my palate has refined
all about that real maple syrup i don't
know there's just something in me that i
feel
i don't feel right eating it my girl
she's who canadian
yeah she's like all fancy pants she gets
like it's like 15 bucks for the little
you know metal bottle or whatever and
you keep that in the [ __ ] fridge
and it's i'm like that's [ __ ] get that
out of here it's a waste i don't know i
just don't [ __ ] with it
i'm not eating [ __ ] waffles i mean
i'll tell you i don't keep waffles in
the house
most of growing up though we did syrup
on
pancakes at the foley household well my
mom would take the syrup she would do 50
50. butter and syrup microwave it or
warm it up in a saucepan
and that's what we would put on the
pancakes but if we were doing french
toast
it was butter and jelly jelly
french toast yeah [ __ ] killer dylan
knows what's up big fat onion
um this is going this just came from the
chaff from sean uh was your
game system in the living room or like a
separate room like if you know like
nintendo or sega or whatever
was that on like the main tv yeah
for a little while yeah and then it went
up to my room
but i thought i feel like those other
rooms are way trashier
why ah it was it was because it was
always a [ __ ] pigsty when you walked
in there yes for kids playing [ __ ]
video games yeah there's like cheetos in
the [ __ ]
couch and [ __ ] like that i'm a big tv
guy
i don't like playing on the side tv yeah
i don't know we never really
my game my first gaming system was
[ __ ] atari we only had one tv
that was the first my first game i was
watching his movies on it
those big silver discs
uh why were you was i what
we were yeah in that room for a while
and then it was always like downstairs
you know like that my parents tried to
get the basement going for like a
[ __ ] rec room for the longest time
but it just never
uh it never got going you know like the
carpet
yeah they redid it but then it flooded
right away and then like it never
[ __ ] it never stopped dude you still
go down there now you're like
this was it smells like it flooded two
weeks ago they've been running a [ __ ]
dehumidifier down there for 25 years
and it still stinks the humidifiers are
garbage yeah and then like you would
have to [ __ ] you know you would
this is did you have a sump pump or you
are like that weird split level [ __ ] so
you don't have like a proper underground
do you yeah we do we have a crawl space
oh dude crawl spaces are bad i used to
think the [ __ ] heebie jeebies lived
in the crawl space
i you you could not pay me to go in
there when i was a little kid
that was we always had to go in there to
[ __ ] fix the pump or do something
like that we had a sump pump i lived
down the basement for
a summer quit bragging it's cool i had
my
you know i was [ __ ] on did you have a
separate entrance no
no those bill code doors uh what i
wanted i had storm doors i priced them
out for a little bit i thought i was
going to be able to [ __ ] have my
bachelor
those things are pretty trashy too those
side those
those doors to go down into a basement
that open up like in the wizard of oz oh
yeah that's like ax murderer [ __ ] dude
the [ __ ] nothing good unless you're
moving a couch or something down there
nothing good is coming in or out of
there
no way i ruined uh my high school
girlfriend's 21st birthday party
surprise party
because of one of those doors she came
in the other way because she saw me
outside
mother was furious so you ruined it i
ruined it
she saw me i went up on one of those
things to smoke and then ran back down
to the basement when i saw a car coming
she was supposed to come down the front
steps and she came down what are you
guys doing here
her mom freaked out we ruined a good
surprise on you
i was on like four hits of incredibly
strong acid at the time too
is that what happened to the shirt
that's where i got this shirt got the
shirt
took a long trip one time in the [ __ ]
70s
never came back it went to numb was
never the same
uh this is from the chat this is from g
rhino this is this one i had on my list
already
and i was going to ask of an upcoming
guest but have you ever purchased used
tires for a car
yeah yeah i'm a bus dude there was a
time period where i was a big
used tire guy big my mom was a big
junkyard rat for a long time
i don't know why i think because she's
[ __ ] garbage what do you mean
i think we were doing okay but she's a
worker and
god love her dude she she'd [ __ ] get
you anything
[ __ ] anyone her way around the
junkyard and the bedroom
oh dude she'd get lights she'd get this
parts for this parts for that
and then she'd have some dude put them
on
that's a real he was putting something
else all right shout out to patty lovely
lady
um yeah that's that's always trash man
if you're like
i get it sometimes if you need like a
fender or something but tigers you
shouldn't
you should you should be spraying the
extra couple of bucks what are you
saving
25 bucks on a tire guys are expensive i
know but i'm saying yeah
it's a tire it's not like a [ __ ] you
know it's not like a mirror or something
that's that's heavy artillery attack
it's your mirror [ __ ]
10 minutes i got one on me where's my
bag oh man
that's a dude i remember this one time i
used to go to this [ __ ]
we had this big work truck and the tires
it was just all like jacked up and the
tires would go like
[ __ ] monthly and i'd go down to the
guy hey look what are you doing
they're just like this old and we kept
putting used tires on it because we were
trying to save pinch
pinch a couple of pennies so it was like
i was down there once a month because
the tires were going because you're like
you're like we're like all construction
equipment so
you know it's like all getting then
you're driving it [ __ ] hours on end
the tires would last i'm [ __ ] they
would like it was so embarrassing i
walked in and i'm like i need a 25 84 19
for a dodge ran like we got this for a
caravan i'm like i'll take it you know
what i mean
[ __ ] one side's all lopsided and [ __ ]
yeah
i think how do you feel about the plug
big plug guy almost real
big plug guy i got him i got my buddy
shout out to vinnie with the skinny
vinny with the skinny nose you know he
knows his way way around some things
and he uh he's got a plug kit he's like
a mechanic type
you know very mechanical kind of guy so
anytime you got a leak yo bring it down
plugs it up you have a sig with them
gives you the skin pretty trashy they
work but they're trashy
yeah but i mean if you're in a jam you
know what i mean you're like i'm not
spending i got a slow
leak i'm not spending [ __ ] you know a
hundred bucks on a tie or whatever
a hundred used that's what you're
getting yeah i'm a used guy 225 i gotta
[ __ ] put a tire on the on the jeep
225. should have your mom [ __ ]
digging
um all right let's see let's see you got
a couple of good ones
here this is great this is fun this is
fantastic
we don't get the it's nice to have a
little uh me and you time yeah a little
[ __ ] breathing room in here you know
just us
just us in the gang i like this stretch
it out a little bit this
um this is this is one i'm very guilty
of
uh this is from kevin not me do you
shave with a disposable razor more than
twice
i don't use razors anymore i use the
razor remember when everybody was
[ __ ] on me like a month ago yeah
[ __ ] foley no chins
yeah because i had a shave for an
audition but usually i don't ever use
a straight razor yeah i always use a
trimmer i [ __ ] hate that feeling
that the ripping through your skin
those two days after you shave it i feel
like [ __ ] wolverine
yeah i don't know i did it for the
longest time because i can't grow a
beard i just started doing this
this is like six months what you haven't
shaved this
no i just i trim it to get that irish
blood i mean
i trim it and i used to just shave once
a week
just shave it every saturday i would
shave but yes but dude i've been using
the same [ __ ] bic razor i'm not even
[ __ ] around with you
for [ __ ] a year and a half oh that's
trash those hairs get in it yeah you
ever use somebody else's in a pinch
yeah i use my brothers a bunch my ladies
every now and then
all my nether regions really i'll go
blade and cream from time to time wait
you shave down there
i have shave shave yeah well the out the
area the
surrounding i like i like a [ __ ]
clean bird okay
i don't like any feathers in my [ __ ]
turkey dinner i'll tell you that much
you don't go near the freedom tower do
you
i will yeah oh that's dangerous game
what are you gonna get a nick a cut
come on i had a skin tag i don't i don't
oh all right
changing subjects skin there's no
questions about skin tags moving on at
the base
and i didn't realize it and i shaved
them it'll look like a herpe that's
stung
all right i do doing your skin tags i
just can't
that's a question now skin tags um this
is from benjamin
do your parents refer to a fancy
restaurant as upscale
talk about not [ __ ] not belonging
what are you doing it's an upscale joke
oh man act like you've been there before
asking for the [ __ ] to overs that is
[ __ ] trash dude
my plate's cold uh upscale upscale
that's a big
telltale sign that you're you know you
don't belong there
it's an upscale restaurant yeah it's
nice because still a classy purse it's
just no it's a nice restaurant it's a
good run it's a nice restaurant
but you think it's better you think the
you think the restaurant's better than
you [ __ ] waiters are all [ __ ]
snobby and [ __ ] to you it's like
i always feel i always take it
personally like when they when you go to
a place
and they say table's gonna be a few
minutes and they send you to the bar
they're trying to get a couple of
[ __ ] bucks out of you
that's paranoid garbage right there i'm
not i got two drink minimum i'm not
paying for them
[ __ ] get me coming and going uh this
is another one this just came in i'm
gonna
forget uh who it came from i don't um
do you ever buy a hermit crab at the
beach oh yeah yeah i won one
at the kennedy kenrick summer fair some
are bizarre got into a big fight
too with the hermit crab you stole my
girl you [ __ ] sucker
now you leave me with him you just met
him
he's only got one hand um
yeah lived for a long time too curiously
long
like years yeah i uh my my nieces and
nephews just down like
as you know i spent a lot of time in
wildwood my nieces and nephews just got
them down there
and like dude they smell like [ __ ]
when they die they don't they smell dead
when they're crawling around dude a
hermit crab cage
mine smelled good i think it was old
spice maybe it's maybelline
maybe it's trash little irish spring um
dude just the smell on them and they
take them out and they like let them
walk around on the floor like they're
[ __ ] dogs and they forget about them
you find one under the couch and [ __ ]
dude those things are [ __ ] sneaky
because you don't even think they're in
there then all of a sudden you look over
and there's [ __ ]
lobsters [ __ ] staring at you [ __ ]
mugging you [ __ ] frightening
yeah i don't like it not to have you
with my [ __ ] filet of fish
i love a good hermit crab it's funny
they're good pets for kids you know
because
you know they're low maintenance you
know what they do now i s
people leaving fairs with like frogs and
turtles and [ __ ] that's a little
that's a little reckless well they made
the turtles illegal those little jaws
because they were like that that was
there was like crazy salmonella with
those
those carry those little [ __ ] what
are they called like quarter jawns or
something
eggs no turtles like the little guys
yeah they carry salmonella turtles carry
salmonella and those
like little silver dollars you got that
from running
from a bad omelette from dippy eggs also
did we talk about that do you have we
talked about that on the air
yeah i thought we did oh calling them
dippy eggs dippy eggs you dip your toast
in there
yeah but i had a buddy order dippy eggs
one time at the restaurant the lady just
looked at the girl was like was down in
wild with
little nicki's on like [ __ ] 17th in
the boardwalk she's like he's like yeah
i'll take the two egg special you know
the egg
like [ __ ] standard breakfast brush
you get the two eggs you get the you get
the hash browns you get the toes
she goes oh how do you want your eggs
and he goes dippy and we were like
[ __ ]
16. i'm like dude i'm about to [ __ ]
[ __ ] bash your skull in
oh my dad haley she she looked at me he
looked at me i'm like i'm not
i'm like fried [ __ ] her she doesn't know
what a she didn't have a loving family
that's her [ __ ] problem that's why
she's working at some slop house in
atlantic city if you're calling them
dippy eggs your family's a little slow
shout out to the [ __ ] my dad makes a
mean dippy egg
cuts them up for you puts a little
ketchup nice
put that right on the toast are you a
make a sandwich guy with your breakfast
i'm a big make a sandwich guy
with the toast what one of my [ __ ]
jerk off
you've met me before something really
good about that you know what's not all
right this is
let me let me [ __ ] give you a little
kr smash here okay
right next time you're reaching for a
breakfast [ __ ] make it a kippy
okay this is what you do if you're going
out there let's say you get the standard
two eggs
two pieces of toast and the [ __ ] you
know and uh hash browns or whatever your
potato however you like your potatoes
some guys go fries i'm not opposed the
standard breakfast special should be
two eggs hash browns bacon or sausage
and white toast yes
exactly so what you do is you take you
make half a sandwich
right because you got two pieces of
bread so you can make half a sandwich
so yeah you can enjoy your sandwich and
also the regular platter style you get a
little bit of best best of both worlds
no i take one of the halves of a toast
and i fold it i'm calling it all toast i
fold it in half
halves of a toast yeah a toast okay what
do you say
not halves of a toast that's not you
sound toast
whatever i'm enjoying my breakfast you
send a little dippy eggs if you know
what i mean
guys this guy's all dipped over here and
then i
could take half of that and then like if
i have an omelet i'll put a little bit
of that a little bit of hash brown
and a little bit of whatever else yeah
yeah fold it up
yeah yeah but i'm saying i also i also i
only do that with one piece i also eat
so i can eat like a platter like a
gentleman
you know of course that's what i'm
saying a little sambal little platter
yeah b-o-b-w
b-o-b-dubs okay this is from the suki
shout out to
is a1 steak sauce garbage
i defer to you i'm saying
my stepdad all the time means it's i'm
saying yeah it's [ __ ] trash
but i don't know there was a time
you know there was a moment where a1
steak sauce
was pretty [ __ ] classy it had a run
right yeah the good marketing behind it
yeah when you taste it now you're like
what the [ __ ]
it's real tangy but you know what's
better than that
what heinz 57 sauce
which is like barbecue mixed with a1
heinz 57 sauce yeah okay check it out
don't the brits do that hp they do it
yeah that's not bad
you get like bangers and mash or
something some they don't really clean
the bottles
kind of gross yeah that's what i'm
[ __ ] worried about the clean bottles
give me the tang that's what i want
kippy wants the tang put it in the sun
yeah i think it's try i think because
the steak's supposed to just be the
[ __ ] steak
the steak's supposed to be cooked well
like that right
it's my understanding no no i always say
you got an
apoiv you put on there a little pepper
sauce little [ __ ] bernay sauce little
hollandaise yeah you're this is all
french [ __ ] you're talking that's an a1
[ __ ]
tr you know a one's trash and they try
to put in that
[ __ ] rapper bottle for a little bit
didn't they you know what's
really good i think it just you just
outgrow it because
it's expensive as [ __ ] but if you're in
the grocery store
and they sell it which they should sell
at most grocery stores across the
country
is peter luger's sauce i never had it's
[ __ ]
in the cooler with the meat yeah that's
how they
real classy and let me tell you
something it's [ __ ] fantastic
fantastic a1 garbage
we should do some of that too before we
before we get out of here what we should
get we should have concrete
rulings on certain things okay that have
been that have been
uh widely discussed on twitter
social media art stuff the big one this
week was this oh someone said
chimichurri
ain't too shabby chimichurri sauce yeah
but that's [ __ ]
fancy that's what i had at my wedding
did you yeah we had steak with jimmy
chatty
i wouldn't know i wasn't invited oh big
man stolen but we need money you come to
uncle hank don't you yeah but you didn't
have any what the [ __ ] the attention was
there
oh god all right
dildo we haven't did you pull any from
uh do you have any on
on deck cause the chat's moving too
[ __ ] fast for me i'm trying to host
the show i can't read
i'm freaking out over here dill no the
the big controversy this week was the uh
the craft
craft macaroni macaroni and cheese
versus elvita this is there's not even a
[ __ ] question here velveeta is the
[ __ ] gold standard
craft is fine but it's trash it's not
i mean it's nowhere near velveeta and
it's velveeta cheese itself
garbage if you're eating of just the
[ __ ] cheese yeah yeah it's [ __ ]
trash
why just eating the cheese it's great no
i'm not saying it's bad it's [ __ ]
trash
is it yeah dude then what are you doing
with the shells
making a necklace what do you mean i'm
not talking about getting a box and just
eating the sauce that
they sell velveeta cheese and oh that
kind of cheese yeah
yeah if you're doing what like a chili
dip or something
let me tell you you chop that up put
that into some [ __ ] scrambie eggs
you got a [ __ ] party yeah that's
perfect it's not too bad
all right what do you got you got a
couple so on the topic of steak uh steak
sauce
how do you like your steak because i
think that does show how garbage you are
because
you go to order a steak what's your
go-to steak and how are you ordering it
i do a filet medium i'm a medium guy
i don't i'm not too fancy you got some
real new money problems
you know that i got some real no money
bro i just didn't shoot a co-sign on a
[ __ ] apartment for me and we failed
we have no money problems the fillet
that's trash filet mignon buddy i just
looked at your
[ __ ] bank statement you were at
mcdonald's you don't see any [ __ ]
fellaini
on there we were at mcdonald's nine
times last week i counted
yeah just fillet of fish i take my
flavor fish medium please
extra pickles
yeah extra mercury back there too how do
you like your imitation crab meat
rare well done for like a raw black and
blue what do you do
what do i do you get a steak medium rare
and it's going to be either a
porterhouse a new york strip
or i'm a big fan of the cheaper cuts
shout out to skirt steak and hanger
steak
yeah i'll give you that look the boys
know what's up yeah for sure
you throw a hanger steak on the grill
[ __ ] good night listen i just don't
know enough about steak so the fillet is
the middle of the road medium's the
middle of a row i don't like
i panic under pr i don't want to pack a
burger medium
okay a medium old medium across the
board will you eat raw meat like will
you have a tartar
a handful of it no no i i have had
uh some tatar uh
yeah but not abs it's like i do it to
you know
[ __ ] shut my wife up when she's like
just try it but yeah i don't i don't
[ __ ] with it
um more of a chicken fingers guy love a
good
chickie thingy shout out
tyson's all right uh yeah what else you
got though
i do uh wha what is your what do you
want to ask what's your deal with a
medium rare
like why why can't we get a steak medium
rare kippy
i got a lot of weird food things and
that's for another so that i
i mean it's uh yeah i just don't know
it's the blood i guess the the
rare unrareness of it i don't i don't
eat red meat that much
more so it's the blood because i i think
the idea of it
i think classy people eat things with
blood of course i'm trash
guys newsflash i am garbage
nice pot roast medium rare slice it up
they're the same people that eat
uh with the fork the other way oh
my wife does that oh that's real classy
when the forks
the upside down fork and you use and you
use the knife to like maybe put a little
something on it
my hands don't work like that i'm like
using my fingers to put corn on the fork
and [ __ ] at home
i can't do that at home i eat most
things with a tablespoon
that's my move quit bragging like if we
get chinese and i'm eating rice
i'm using a big big tablespoon got the
ladle out
where are these questions coming from is
just you asking us this i know i got no
this
i am looking at the chat so i'm trying
to pick out the best this is another one
i do like
and i'm gonna change it dylan's getting
some date night ideas
[Laughter]
um have does anyone in your family has
ever owned a pool table
or a um what's it uh air hockey table or
a hockey table anything
yeah this is a very common one we've
gotten this a bunch
um yeah where you've been we've asked
that question the last
five weeks yeah they're i mean we had a
ping pong table growing up that's how
trashy we were we took it from my mom
from my dad bought a ping pong table and
we took it from my dad's house
to my mom's house for just for one party
just so we could play at the party just
ping pong
that's how [ __ ] we thought we were
like the [ __ ] we're like wait till
[ __ ]
sean and liam get here we're gonna
[ __ ] blow their minds with this
ping-pong table
then that's fine by the way we had to
like take a door off the hinges to get
it down the basement we scuffed up the
[ __ ] walls
knocked over the dehumidifier it's real
trashy when you're renting [ __ ] for a
party isn't it
when they're loading oh yeah we rent it
like uh
or my family rent it like uh like a like
a blow up water park
for somebody's birthday recently i mean
the kid was little
yeah but i'm saying recently a couple
years ago yeah that's recently
yeah yeah it got real sloppy it gets
real messy that's like the same thing
with like the backyard with like the
homemade slip and slides with the big
tarp and the [ __ ] palm olive and [ __ ]
you're all right
yeah they're good time but it's trash
you know what's [ __ ] was real where
my neighbors
they were married no kids his name was
ducky that's what we called him
i got a car to talk to him doctor real
cool guy what had car that talked to him
back and he was like a tech nerd and he
had this like blue camaro that talked to
him like knight rider
it said like two things and it was
pre-programmed yeah yeah i mean it
wasn't a.i dude it wasn't this wasn't
this
wasn't i mean this wasn't irobot showing
up at park it was like hello ducky and
then with like you know cough or
something wait what kind of car was it
some blue trans am oh you know some real
trash 90s [ __ ] high rock z the z28
those are trans
anything great cool looking car any car
that was available
with t-tops you're [ __ ] trash
that's the cut-off sleeves of cars
my buddy had a shout out to vinnie with
the skinny vinny with the skinny had the
[ __ ]
the trans am or something with the
t-tops yeah and i'm like
what are we in a winger video what are
we doing here i can't do it put this
[ __ ] up i can't hear anything you can't
hear the music
i can't do a coupe either a two-door oh
get the [ __ ] there i no way am i getting
in the back seat of a [ __ ] two-door
car
ever yeah well i mean the [ __ ] laws
of physics
i mean but it's like you feel you have
to put your strong soul
yeah it's tough the rear views are the
the [ __ ] back windows right there
yeah i don't like that [ __ ] uh what else
you got dill
how many languages can you swear in
that is pretty trashy really yeah i can
swear in hebrew that's the only thing i
know in hebrews
curse words yeah because you're not
learning a lot you're just learning
[ __ ]
dirtbag words in another language i know
a couple spanish curse words but i
thought that would be pretty classy if
you could speak another language
you thought you were [ __ ] johnny you
thought you were [ __ ] juan valdez
last weekend when we left here
and there was that spanish guy passed
out drunk under your car
and you were like like you like mumbled
through nine spanish words the guy
looked at like what the [ __ ] is this
fact he was a diplomat i was trying to
be
courteous
the guy had no idea what the [ __ ] he was
saying [ __ ] he
he was laying in a pile of [ __ ] 55
trash bags
laying under with his legs under my car
but i'll tell you what when i went over
and spoke to him in his native language
he was a [ __ ] perfect gentleman he
snapped right at him he's like
he's like oh thank you sir sorry about
that no problem sir take care
yeah he was a little uh he was a little
banged up uh have you ever ordered
anything off qvc
or television yeah you know i have like
a [ __ ]
my pillow's out the ass shout out to
mike lindell
my pillow yeah we all saw the video
check out my video
i plugged the video that was always a
scam to uh that was one of those things
that that's a [ __ ] scam you don't
yeah but there was a couple of things i
understand the day that you just got
yeah you know you just got it even
though it did suck
like the big mouth billy bass that was
the [ __ ] you just got that
you ordered that no we didn't have that
the blue blockers we ordered them
the whole [ __ ] family was from you
know blue blockers
the [ __ ] the blue blocker the
sunglasses those ate those 80s
sunglasses
you don't remember those when they hit
the big the drawings that you put over
the pair sling
looks like you just went to the
optometrist those things the grandma
glasses no
no they sell it rite aid what am i a
[ __ ] transformer
no transformers fat guy
in disguise donut look at my eyes
that guy in tai dai come on kippy's
eating up
he needs some money to get an apartment
for his
swimming in your underwear trash wait
hold on what you know you don't remember
blue blockers
uh no for the ninth time i don't know
what they are maybe they were called
something else i've heard the term i
just don't know what they are
the whole dude one easter the whole
family had them we looked like the
[ __ ] dominican connection
standing in the back of the church
everybody everybody looked like they
were in the cartel
even the kids dude we all have the kids
the kids can get you a [ __ ] cheap
price on a kilo keep
it moving by the way kids in sunglasses
and also kids with cool haircuts what
are we doing yeah every kid's an
instagram model now
you're a little if you're a parent and
you give your little kid
a cool haircut and he wears sunglasses
to a party
he's old enough to get punched in the
[ __ ] face if he runs his mouth
yeah that should be the rule yeah i
don't know i mean i never got a good
haircut dude i show up to family parties
my kids look like
all my nieces and nephews look like
[ __ ] james dean and [ __ ] they got
like a leather jacket on they're smoking
cigs i don't know i don't know what's
happening [ __ ] cool fade they got
that european soccer haircut
somebody's saying the the louis glasses
i got you i got you um
kind of but they were they were more
plasticky all right i mean i get the
idea there are sunglasses
so what underwear that's always trash if
you don't if you don't have a bathing
suit or someone to give you a bathing
suit or wherever you at like if you're
swimming in a friend's pool or something
in your [ __ ] skivvies
and your friends pull sure but but hold
on let's not
you're swimming in your pool in your
underwear
i don't like the feel of
you know big baggy bathing suits and i
hate that [ __ ] mesh netting that's in
there i usually cut that out
and let it all hang loose but when
everybody goes home at my parents if
it's like [ __ ]
you know at night or early in the
morning i go in there in my underwear
because it's looser it feels more
comfortable yeah that's trashy buy a
bigger
that's that's lazy garbage just buy a
bigger
go you're at walmart every two days but
i don't do [ __ ] shirts and the water
gets in the pockets when you get out
in this [ __ ] stock what are you
wearing his [ __ ] suit in there
pockets your bathing suits don't have
pockets i don't know i don't have a
bathing suit
i have one bathing suit where are you
going to keep your money for the snack
bar
i get those i got an account at the
snack bar eat some [ __ ] chili fries
uh
for the road all right this is from
thomas what is the most common cheese
you ate
american yeah were you craft singles
no too expensive we were all my my
parents were big deli counter people
they love the deli counter yeah
pound of american pound of turkey pound
of roast beef pound of ham
that was the week got you guys through
lunch
[Laughter]
and whatever they wanted i uh i
my mom did it nice we did the like the
16 pack of the craft singles
you know and then yellow or white white
really yeah interesting yellows new york
[ __ ]
everywhere else you go you get white
cheese you go to philadelphia all the
shit's white cheese no i'll craft
my craft singles are all yellow because
you're trash white
the cheese you get the countering y'all
you're getting yellow cheese at the
counter
sometimes no white cheese it was a good
week
boar's head don't have yellow i'm
kidding no we get [ __ ] white
that's getting real american though what
yeah yeah real american and then the
but if you get crafted it was still
white but we would only use the the
craft took
to cook to heat like grilled cheese
on top of eggs or whatever okay and then
the the american
slice thin by the way so thin you can
barely see it
you know it's one of my fondest like
overall memories and i would just eat
cheese sandwiches okay continue
and maybe now continue a couple of
pretzels on there nice saturday
afternoon
yeah the old lady just got back from the
store yeah
she's whipping up some lunch lunch is
gonna be some [ __ ]
nice lunch meat on a [ __ ] fresh loaf
of bread
and some [ __ ] fresh pickies from the
store with a fresh bag of chips
maybe a little saudi [ __ ] on a nice
saturday
dude tonight come on uh you can't beat
that
this is one i think we've talked about
too this is from uh george or jorge what
did you carry your lunch in a brown
paper bag or a real lunch bag
i brought straight cash [ __ ] i
was cash for a long time i wasn't gonna
be one of those [ __ ]
i remember my mom tried to send me with
like a [ __ ] can of coke and a [ __ ]
peanut butter sandwich by the time i got
to lunch
the pizza [ __ ] the peanut butter
sandwich was wrapped around the can of
coke in the plastic bag what are you
working security overnight
at a construction site get out those
doors
hey parks closed buddy no we did uh
we we packed but she did it right pv and
j's
[ __ ] little debbie uh oatmeal cream
pies
uh uh high cs she did it nice but then
we always got a
little bit of [ __ ] a little bit of
walking around cash if you got to make a
purchase make a trade
you need a little bit of flexibility in
the lunchroom as a kid you can't just go
one way or the other
you got to have a little something on
you a little cat i know i was i was big
that would hit me off with a fiver or
something to five back in like junior
high or high school
you're renting the place out [ __ ] at
a private party [ __ ] kidding me
[ __ ] ding-dongs for everybody
you're tipping the luncheons kids were
eating
um okay let's see that we never did this
but
was uh a question do you ever
okay this is from dead stretch uh did
you ever stand out in front of a
supermarket or anything asked for
quarters or change saying it was for a
pay phone call
only to try to get five bucks to buy a
nickel bag of weed
jesus christ buddy seek help
please leave the chat would you grow up
in the 50s who's doing that
shout out to dead stretch i've seen his
name before yeah for sure he's a great
great guy um that's
i mean that's tom that's not even
garbage
that was like the guy the other remember
the guy the other day on twitter was
like yeah they're asking about cheese
and [ __ ] what about
[ __ ] your buddy's girl or even a
hitting run yeah you're just a bad
person that's not growing up trash
let's keep it light here will you yeah
this guy um
um no i i i i've never i've never been a
uh
i can't ask people for money like that
no no no no no no i couldn't stand there
hey man you have a quarter
i just can't do it no not at all um so
no
this is a good one this is from jason
how are the hot dogs cooked in your
household were they grilled fried
microwaved or
boiled wow yeah who's that that was from
what did i say jason shout out to jason
that's the [ __ ] question of the
episode
right there that is a [ __ ] fantastic
question
that tells so much about a family
now that being said
mr ryan yes what season is it
i don't know whatever i mean if it's the
summer the fall or the spring
well you're gonna have to be cooked
they're cooked on the grill otherwise
you're garbage
sure yes of course boiled i'm a boiled
guy
we boiled them do you still boil hot
dogs
if you're boiling hot dogs in your new
york city apartment you're [ __ ] trash
there's no two ways around it it doesn't
smell like a [ __ ] aquarium
drink the water
why is hot dog water so bad
why it's it's the only thing that's like
[ __ ] astronomically worse
than a hot dog i don't know what what
happens
um no my girl does him in the pan yeah
pan's all right so we
i was a big big
oscar meyer cheese dog guy with the
cheese in them buddy
right i can't get her to buy them i
[ __ ] love them so good
i would take two of them put them on a
paper plate
throw it in the microwave for an easy
minute stop it at maybe two or three
seconds left so they don't pop
because those things pop they get going
that cheese starts [ __ ] spraying out
of there like a pipe
those microwave hot dogs they look like
chewed cigars
ah wow what do you hear what do you say
they look really bad um but i remember
as a kid we would
my my aunt would boil them and then we'd
go to the beach he'd put them in a
cooler of just hot water
and you'd like open it up like you were
working a hot dog stand get like a
tongue or a fork or whatever pull it out
put like a wet hot dog into a [ __ ]
stale bun
[ __ ] seagulls swooping at you dude
that was [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] disgusting somebody just
called me or you a wiener sommelier
wait where where were the buns in a bag
somewhere
you're making the hot dogs on the on
them we're not making them you're
assembling them
you know what i mean we're not [ __ ]
making them i mean that's i think i
might have talked about this once last
year i saw a guy with a [ __ ] pound a
pound of ham a pound of cheese a pound
of turkey making a hoagie on the [ __ ]
wildwood beach
what kind of [ __ ] animal do you have
to be
make it at home what's the point make it
in the car
that's [ __ ] disgusting dude he's he's
got like a towel over because the
seagulls
sequels to three pounds of lunch meat
they're freaking the [ __ ] out
so they're [ __ ] swooping dive bomb
and it's a whole [ __ ] scene and he's
got like a towel over his head trying to
make a [ __ ] shorty
he's cut the mayo out and [ __ ] oh it was
a [ __ ] scene dude
that's garbage yeah all right so hold on
let's get an official ruling on this
all right uh so moving forward yeah
you're [ __ ] trash
all right [ __ ] hot dog cooler i don't
know what the [ __ ] that's all about yeah
i'm not proud so
hot dogs on the beach what are you
eating hot food on the beach for what
the [ __ ]
what's that about you drinking coffee we
were like a couple of seconds
poor dude we had to feed like fish get a
[ __ ] sandwich
cold we had to feed like 15 kids so you
could just do
velveeta did you put a spoonful of
velveeta what do you mean
i don't know you shouldn't be eating hot
food on the beach listen decisions i
didn't make decisions i was just living
with the ramifications
and a diesel after a [ __ ] day of
[ __ ] boogie boarding
good mate as they say or buenos noches
to our
to our hispanic listeners that the
[ __ ] screamer [ __ ] from the cooler
yeah nice
ice cold coke maybe a fudgy wudgy shout
out to the fudgy wudgy man
love those guys yeah wait all right so
obviously if you can the hot dog should
be grilled
secondly would be they're done in a pan
third would be you boil them
however if you do them in a pan
and you're one of those [ __ ]
jerk-offs that cuts the hot dog down the
middle
go [ __ ] yourself the the stripes
[ __ ] the stripes are different yeah
he ends up with a little corkscrew on a
grill which is nice
yeah but shout out to this one people
slice them down the middle and it's this
[ __ ] like limp dick open [ __ ]
hot dog yeah get out of here um
all right this one is from we gotta we
gotta wrap it up in a couple of minutes
here we go this one's from skeeler
uh she's yelling at me kippy you're
reading the chat have you ever built
owned or fired a potato cannon
yeah in college we had them we used to
have potato gun fights with the other
fraternity houses
until somebody took one in the face
sounds like a real cool frat
yeah forget these parties and chicks
let's go shoot [ __ ] vegetables at
each other
[ __ ] idiot there's a lot of engineers
on my fraternity
in college so they made one okay
what there were so they still wearing
tie-dye shirts now too
um i uh i had an egg can and an egg
launcher we had i had to build for
school
and my step-dad's like medieval studies
my stepdad's a real macgyver kind of guy
so he's like why would you have to build
an egg cannon first and we were like
uh where the [ __ ] did you go dude
i'm learning a lot about you hot dogs on
the [ __ ] beach egg cannons
it was like a pulley system it was like
a simple machine you know what i mean
like in a spring or whatever
or like a you know i don't know it was
like a science like a fun science
project whoever shoots the egg the
furthest
and we spent hours and probably [ __ ]
three grand on this thing research and
development yeah and the [ __ ] egg
never got out of the can and it kept
breaking i felt like a real jamoke
that's a weird we we
we did the classy version of that which
is you built a parachute for an egg
and then at the end of the year they the
they drop it off the building
to see if it if it made it or not you
think that's classy
then a [ __ ] egg salad gun whoever the
[ __ ] you're doing
i could throw potato salad at each other
in the lunch room
you're [ __ ] dumb-ass gold classy
um all right guys fire off a couple more
and then we gotta we gotta roll
um let's see and listen we're gonna do
we'll do this periodically
yeah well i think we're gonna do it once
a month just to uh you know get um
all maybe not once a month but we're
gonna do it periodically okay
we'll see what happens um
i don't know you having fun are you
enjoying this i'm having a great time
buddy
um let's see
there's some of these are a little dicey
if you know what i mean give us a dicey
one
when was the last time you had a road
soda drinking and driving
either you and the you may be not
necessarily driving the car but
you're drinking in the car uh
20 years ago what's the statute of
limitations on an open container
because kippy might have to bleed the
fourth fifth and sixth on that one
pouring it into a soda cans real trash
yeah there's a couple of people that i
know
that uh put it into a wawa coffee cup
and call it their afternoon coffee a
real
tree but i will say this when
uh when we went down to miami beach all
right
shout out to south beach yeah uh we got
uh we went to 7-eleven and we got like
you know
like like a thermos or whatever okay and
loaded that up with [ __ ]
vodka and fruit juice got all tuned up
on the beach
okay on that um yeah
uh i got caught in philadelphia one time
by a cop i was drinking in the back seat
of a car
and he was just like he's like i caught
you i'm like all right i'm sorry i'm
like it's empty and like
started freaking out and he goes dump it
out i go okay
no problem it gets empty i'm sorry you
know and he goes real tough guy yeah i
panicked immediately i turned state's
evidence
real quick uh and he goes uh
he goes now i'm just [ __ ] with you he
goes is the driver drinking i go no no
no
he might have been i go no no no and he
goes all right have a good night and
then he blew through a red light i was
like
philly philly cops and [ __ ]
kensington playing fast and loose yikes
yeah ah all right let's see one more and
then we get out of here
what do you say there big man i love it
we appreciate all you guys it's been so
much fun
i hope you guys are digging this yeah um
yeah we'll find out
i guess that's the main thing i'm
worried about is everyone good
chat's having a big uh white sox black
socks debate
what's that uh white or black socks
that's what's going on in the chat
whites
white socks are for [ __ ] goobers
black socks all day
yeah black socks talking about the
baseball teams right uh black socks all
day and ankles
yeah all ankles unless it's like
fashionable but if you're just a guy
wearing like [ __ ] white tube socks
yeah come on with like you know get it
together that's trash take it take a
little pride in your appearance why you
don't want to take your shoes off
white socks do you have holes in your
socks right now i don't have socks on
what are you wearing
you have flip flops on no sneakers
you're raw dogging it in a pair of nikes
yeah summer time yeah even worse
no socks no underwear plates fast and
loose that's a tight
shirt that's officially his chair moving
forward all right this will be the last
one
for dinner parties dinner parties
soirees uh
family holiday dinners did your parents
have to get the table extender inserts
from storage
and the metal folding chairs from under
your bed extra garbage credit if the
kids table was patio furniture tables
and chairs that they brought in from
outside
yes across the board yeah and i was the
[ __ ] jerkoff that had to go get the
extender
that was our one job it's [ __ ] i
don't know why it seemed like it was
such a big deal but it was you guys were
using it as a bunk bed
[Laughter]
had to move the dog yes to that
yes to the [ __ ] folding chairs and
yes to the [ __ ] kids table being
uh yeah something we had like we still
have a [ __ ]
green flimsy card table from like i
might it must be the [ __ ]
1920s this thing's [ __ ] pre-war you
know when i found out that other
families had kids tables it blew my mind
i thought we were the only only ones
yeah like what you guys had a kids table
too my family's so big and it's like
it's like cliche to say but my family's
so big
and i fell in the weird there's like a
five year gap between me and everybody
dude i had to
i'm no lie i had to sit at the kids
table until i was like [ __ ]
in college at times where i was sitting
at the kids table with like
my [ __ ] with like my cousin's kids so
they would be like tops
yeah i was having a couple of
chardonnays you know you're drinking
this talking about the stock market with
the toddler the sparking sparkling apple
cider
yeah i love that [ __ ] so good yeah um
guys that's it thank you so much
yeah we appreciate it this has been
[ __ ] awesome this has been a lot of
fun i hope you guys enjoyed it we hope
so let us know if you enjoyed it
uh yeah guys also too if you haven't
already please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
uh get us back into that top two hundo
we're floating we're in and out every
couple of days
uh please make sure you rate review
subscribe and by the way i see the
number of people that listen on [ __ ]
itunes
there's a lot of people that can be
leaving reviews that aren't leaving
reviews that's all i'm saying
yeah leave a review also please uh
subscribe on youtube full videos there
even if you don't watch the [ __ ]
youtube just [ __ ] go subscribe you
got a youtube account go subscribe
juice those numbers a bit you know pump
and dumb schemes buy low sell high
and uh if you want to join uh gas
digital for all the [ __ ] benefits all
the library libraries a lot of people
were trashing me because i said library
in the
i remember that yeah i got a [ __ ] you
have real trash you guys eating hot dogs
[ __ ]
on the beach um water that's you can you
can get all the catalogs of all the old
shows of all you know legion of skanks
it's
thousands and thousands of hours of
content you get and if you use promo
code ayg we get to wet our beak a little
bit
it'll be a good [ __ ] time so do it
guys yes we appreciate you guys we love
you guys
and we'll see you next week peace